The reason why this discourse about tribe wives
has such racial undertones
and white supremacist undertones
is because of this.
Feminism at its core
is trying to gain women the same sort of
autonomous independence as men are afforded.
And when you look at the most important voices
on this topic in feminism,
they are POC voices
because the fight for personhood has been much longer
for them than it has been for white women,
who have been afforded this conditional privilege
by being subservient and in service to white men.
Which is why I try white content
without any sort of explanation
is just marketing
for the gilded cage of white supremacy for white women.
We will keep you happy,
we will keep you comfortable.
You don't have to worry about the bills, honey,
cause I've got it covered.
And it looks very appealing.
Because there always will be women who are, uh,
drawn to and love the idea of a slower life,
of being able to take care of your kids
and take care of your home.
That's the lifestyle that I personally have and enjoy.
But it's very different to enjoy something
when there are other option.
You have full
autonomous personhood.